[Music]
haven't asked this bridge we received by
that Lord Montezuma with about two
hundred Chiefs all barefooted and
dressed in a kind of livery very rich
according to their customs and some more
so than others
they approached in two processions near
the walls of the street which is very
broad and straight and beautiful and
very uniform from one end to the other
being about two-thirds of a league long
and having on both sides very large
houses both dwelling places and mosques
Montezuma came in the middle of the
street with two Lords one on the right
side and the other one on the left one
of whom was the same great Lord who as I
said came in that later to speak with me
and the other was the brother of
Montezuma Lord of that city is tap pala
pan whence I come that day all dressed
in the same manner except the Montezuma
was shot and the other lords were
barefooted each supported him below his
arms and as we approached each other I
descended from my horse
I was about to embrace him but the two
lords and attendants prevented me with
their hands that I might not touch him
and he also made the ceremony of kissing
the ground the standing heel did his
brother who came with him to remain with
me and take me by the arm and the other
attendant walk turns ahead of us after
he had spoken to me all the other lords
who formed the two processions also
saluted me one after the other and then
returns to the procession when I
approached to speak to Montezuma I took
off a collar of pearls and cast diamonds
that I wore and put it on his neck and
after we had gone through some of the
streets one of his servants came with
two collars wrapped in a cloth which
were made of coloured shells these they
esteem very much and from each of the
collars hung eight golden shrimps
executed with great perfection and a
span long
when he received them he turned towards
me and put them on my neck and again
went on through the streets as I've
already indicated until we came to a
large and handsome house which he had
prepared for our reception there he took
me by the hand and led me into a
spacious room in front of the court
where we had entered where he made me
sit on a very rich platform which had
been ordered to be made for him and told
me to wait there and then he went away
after a little while when all the people
of my company were distributed to their
quarters he returned with many valuables
of gold and silver work and five or six
thousand pieces of rich cotton stuffs
woven and embroidered in diverse ways
after he had given them to me he sat
down on another platform which they
immediately prepared near the one I was
seated and being seated he spoke in the
following manner we have known for a
long time from The Chronicles of our
forefathers that neither I nor those who
inhabit this country are descendants
from the Aborigines of it but from
strangers who came to it from distant
parts and we also hold that our race was
brought to these parts by a lord whose
vassals they all were and who returned
to his native country after a long time
he came back but it was so long that
those who remained here were married
with the native women of the country and
had many descendants and had built towns
where they were living when therefore he
wished to take them away with him they
would not go nor still less receive him
as their ruler so he departed and we've
always held that those who descended
from him would come to subjugate the
country and us as his vassals and
according to the direction from which
you say you come which is where the Sun
rises and from what you tell us of your
great Lord or king who has sent to you
here we believe and hold force
certain that he is our rightful
sovereign especially as you tell us that
since many days he has had news of us
hence you may be sure that we shall obey
you and hold you as the representative
of this Great Lord of whom you speak and
that in this there will be no lack or
deception and throughout the whole
country you may command at your will I
speak of what I possess in my Dominion
because you will be obeyed and
recognized and all we possess is at your
disposal
[Music]
since you are in your rightful place and
in your own homes rejoice and rest free
from all the trouble of the journey and
Wars which you have had and I am well
aware of all that has happened to you
between Ponton Canon here and I know
very well that the people of Campo el
and task el TECA have told you many evil
things respecting me do not believe more
than you see with your own eyes
especially from those that are my
enemies and were my vassals yet rebelled
against me on your coming as they say in
order to help you I know they have told
you that I have houses with walls of
gold and that the furniture of my halls
and other things of my service were also
of gold and that I am or make myself a
god and many other things the houses you
have seen or of lime and stone and earth
and then he held up his robes and
showing me his body he said to me look
at me and see that I am flesh and bones
the same as you and everybody and that I
am mortal and tangible and touching his
arms and body with his hands look how
they have lied to you
it is indeed true that I have some
things of gold which have been left to
me by my forefathers who would I possess
you may have whenever you wish
[Music]
I shall now go to other houses where I
live but you will be provided here with
everything necessary for you and your
people and you should suffer no
annoyance for you are in your own house
and country I answer to all these said
certifying that which seemed to be
suitable especially in confirming belief
that it was your majesty whom they were
expecting after this he took his leave
and when he had gone we were well
provided with chickens and bread and
fruits and other necessities especially
such as were required for the service of
our quarters thus I passed six days well
provided with everything necessary and
visited by many of the Lords
[Music]
[Music]
you